Kristen I it's been a while since we've
seen you on TV
it has you are you are out of the
trenches yes I am that's a really good
way to put it and completely out of the
trenches yes I may not be the sharpest
tool in the shed but I'm pretty
and I loved every minute of it I just I
just don't think I really fit in I think
that's okay two years of normal people
could take but then they're like where's
the crazy you know she used to drink the
bore or something right so you're
watching the show as a viewer a fan now
yes what's that experience like it's
interesting it's fun to see what all the
girls are doing but without the drama
Josh and I were watching it and it was
like there was a moment where I was like
oh gosh she was like oh my god that's
crazy like I can't wait to get through
this commercial but at the same time
you're I said to Malik but that's her
life like oh my god that's real I'm
going to talk about you brought up Josh
there's a little bit of a scandal last
year scandal you mean my nail polish
color scandal is it inspired by yes of
course making it through that did only
make you stronger yeah I know 100% yeah
I just kind of feel like you know
looking back it's like I I know my truth
and our truth and our relationship and I
just feel like I'm not on a reality TV
show anymore and I don't really have to
explain it to anybody so that's kind of
how I'm leaving you know yeah you take
yourself off TV yeah your life is
private again yeah exactly
I started a blog I started a fashion
blog you are keeping busy with the blog
and pop of color yes I know you have
some here yeah after inviting it take a
look at what I'm wearing it this is a
little less conversation so everything
is inspired by Elvis oh because you're
obsessed exactly it's like my mother
nail polish and a lip gloss line where
am I gonna draw my inspiration from